it's all about execution and action you
have to be very specific you can't just
suddenly start thinking differently you
need to translate that desire to change
into like what does it look like and
what are the doable repeatable
sustainable actions that you can take
every single day protect them and
prioritize them so that they're
repeatable and sustainable within the
construct of your busy life the people
who are successful are the people who
are able to make those tiny invisible
Atomic tweaks repeat them enough until
they become rote and then build upon
them so their lifestyle shifts gradually
in proportion to the changes that are
being made and you kind of expand in
this organic gradual way